For this module you're going to want
to open up the playground file in title
Lesson2_Optional.
Here's an example of what I mean
when I say nil is disallowed in most
Swift types.
If I declare an int variable x and
try to assign it a nil value,
I get the following error message.
Cannot assign a value of type
nil to a value of type int.
Ints can't store nil values and neither
can any of the other primitive types.
This isn't all that surprising.
It's more surprising to see that object
references can't store nil values.
Here's a reference to a UI color object.
It can store a UI color,
UIcolor.redcolor, but not nil.
That's unusual.
This isn't true in Java, C++,
Ruby, Python, C#, Objective C,
they all have nil or null or some
special value that stands in for null.
Notice that even if we change
the variable c to be an object of type
any object.
The data type for
a general object reference, we can
see that it still can't store nil.
In a way this is cool.
This means null pointer
exceptions are impossible.
But what about situations for
which we need nil values?
Let's think.
Under what conditions would
a value need to be no?
Let's explore the two
most common scenarios.
The first has to do with
values returned from methods.
There are some cases in which
it wouldn't make sense for
a method to return a value.
A good example is this init method.
This method is used to
initialize an int from a string.
But not all strings can
be converted to ints.
What should happen when s2
is converted to an int?
It definitely can't
return an integer value.
But throwing a fatal error isn't
a much better alternative.
We can see that the compiler agrees.
Something is wrong here.
It's important that a method
like this int initializer
can return something that
represents no value or none.
Declaring y as a type Int isn't enough.
We need a type that has two options,
either an Int value or no value.
We can't pretend that
nil values don't exist.
Another common scenario that we'll see,
especially when working with UIKit,
has to do with properties of instances.
Often classes of properties
that can't be initialized until
after an instance is constructed.
Consider the simple ViewController.
Notice that the compiler won't allow
me to add this button property.
Why is that?
The problem is that the button
is a regular Swift variable, and
Swift variables can't store nil values.
So what value should this button member
store when a view controller is created?
Just like the method
return types before,
in this situation we need options.
We often need to instantiate
a ViewController first, and
then initialize its properties later.
This is especially true when
we're using storyboard.
Swift needs a way for
this button variable to either
have a button value or to be nil.